MARTIN: Here is a
pet peeve of mine.
Many companies define what
they aren't instead of
what they are.
It's the same when
we say serverless.
The name says what
it isn't, servers,
but it doesn't say what it is.
This can be confusing
to business people.
Could we come up
with a better name?
One way would be to think
about why organizations
choose to go serverless.
Businesses like the
autoscaling and pay per use
they get from serverless.
But when I talk to
them, most of them
tell me they picked serverless
for two other reasons.
One, it's easier
to hire developers.
They don't have to know Linux
or Kubernetes to be productive.
Two, there is less ops work to
maintain a serverless system
once it's been built.
Maybe our new word
for serverless
should reflect this reality.
I will keep using
the term serverless
in my videos for now,
just so that people
know what I'm talking about.
But what word would you
prefer instead of serverless?
Let's discuss in
the comments below.